waiting for their next dispatch to Red
Cross workers on standby at this office
in Ecatepec Mexico here half of the
ambulance units have been refitted to
specifically deal with koban 19 patients
but the paramedics say they're worried
the region's hospitals are nearing
capacity I think we should be worried
about the level of saturation at
hospitals because we've arrived in an
ambulance and found there is no space
for our patients we have to wait 1 2 3
I've had to wait for up to four hours in
independent analysis of more than 4,500
death certificates is adding concern the
region's health system could soon become
overwhelmed the findings suggest the
death toll in Mexico City is actually 3
times higher than what the government is
reporting VNA act as a fonzie under fire
see mentos and gases there are death
certificates of people who either did
not know they had the illness or died in
quarantine without being tested testing
is certainly a factor also they are not
adequately reporting the deaths of
people under the suspicion of
coronavirus we see that Mexican health
officials are not denying the findings
of the new report but mexico's deputy
health minister Google Lopez Goodell is
questioning the methodology he says that
a majority of the death certificates in
question are part of the subset that
will eventually be included in an
official COBIT 19 death toll Mexico City
and its surrounding municipalities have
become the epicenter of the corona virus
outbreak in the country people seeking
medical treatment are finding it
increasingly difficult to find hospitals
that are still accepting patients as
hospitals in Mexico City continued to
fill up people are turning to a mobile
phone application launched by the city
government that indicates which
hospitals have reached capacity as of
this week all but five of the region's
medical centers appeared either
completely full or nearing capacity
paramedics say calls related to kovat 19
are still on the rise making the
workload constant they are also worried
an oversaturation of hospitals could
lead to patients dying while waiting in
the back of ambulances
Manuel rapido al-jazeera Mexico City